- We have an audience question
for the cast. Where is Cruz?
- [Cruz] Right here, right here.
- [Clarkson] What's up Cruz?
- Hi, how's it going?
- [Clarkson] You can stand
up, what's your question?
- Okay, so I have a question for you guys.
So, I'm obviously a big Marvel fan,
and it has taught me a lot of
really valuable life lessons.
But, I want to know
what has it taught you?
Like being part of the Marvel Universe.
- Oh, Elizabeth would
you like to go first?
- Sure, well, I think the
character I play, Wanda.
She's made lots of,
she's very opinionated and through that,
has also found herself making mistakes.
And I think it's important for us
to watch people make mistakes.
I mean I think do that pretty well
with a lot of our characters.
And I think it's important
to show that kind of process,
working through suffering of
different kinds, from that.
And, so I guess it's-
- [Kelly] It's real.
- Yeah, so it's been,
I think I have appreciated
getting to explore that
through this.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- What about you, Benedict C?
(Gomez chuckling)
- Benedict C, yeah, it's again
through the character, I guess.
I mean, through making a Marvel film,
you learn, a lot.
(laughing)
A lot to do with patience
and pacing yourself.
- Lots of patience.
- But also, I think the
characters do always,
that's what's great about
them. There's great laughs,
there's great action,
there's sort of enticement
for a spectacle, as you know.
But, there's also
something of the Zeitgeist
or something profound to takeaway.
For me, for him, especially in this one,
it's learning that you
are stronger together
than you are on your own.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's pretty much the lesson I carry away
from this one, without
giving away too much.
- [Kelly] Boy, drive that
one home for the world.
- [Olsen] Yeah.
- [Clarkson] Yeah. (laughing)
Listen!
- Yes. Yes.
- What about you, Benedict W? (chuckling)
- I've just enjoyed
overall, what Marvel do,
with these incredible films, you know,
it's about inclusion and how we represent
many people, of color.
And again, as I talked about the platform
and opportunities that
we have with 'Shang-Chi'
and now,
- Oh, I love.
- we have 'Miss Marvel' coming up
and everybody gets to see
that they can have a hero
that they can follow, so.
- Absolutely.
- I love, yeah.
- So, it's so important
because I think a lot
of times people are like, you know,
they want to see themselves,
but also it's important
for other people to see
other people in these roles.
- [Cruz] Yeah.
- [Clarkson] That's
the bigger picture too,
is like, to make sure
you're seeing everyone
for those kids, as well.
- Yeah.
- [Clarkson] Marvel does
such a great job with that,
I feel like.
- Yeah.